Candid Truth. What's up everybody? Thank
you for joining us at Candid Truth.
We're going to talk about the truth and
we're going to get candid with it. 2025
continues to be the strangest year ever.
And it's only May. I mean, we've had a
pope die and the first ever American
pope be elected. We've had Trump saying
that he's the king of Babylon and going
to run a third term and basically he can
write any religious law he wants to
under Project 2025. This is the year
that the occult has been saying is very
prophetic. We're going into the age of
Aquarius, the golden age, and that
there's going to be an externalization
of the hierarchy,
and we're seeing UFOs everywhere. That's
the externalization. I mean, this is
crazy. We're only five months in. So,
science has now turned lead into gold.
This is alchemy. If you don't know what
alchemy is, it's science and sorcery.
This goes way back to medieval times.
Like the first time I really heard of it
was that anime um Full Metal Alchemist
and that's when I like looked into it.
But this is all all the news right now
is talking about this that scientists
have turned lead into gold. What do you
think about that? Very symbolic uh in
the occult. Very lots of meaning there
um which I want to dive into. Um, but
we're gonna have to go a little deeper
in just a minute. All right, let's check
this out. So, this is this is all like
two days ago, three days ago. I mean,
this is brand new stuff here. Yeah. So,
obviously the articles that are coming
out, they clearly state that this
happened all at CERN, that they created
that piece of gold for a split second in
their machines. And um we're going to be
diving into that a little more too about
CERN. But CERN um let's go to the next
slide if we can. So as you know this may
or may not have a very obvious
connection to
you. I mean it occurred to you that this
a connection but we have this happening.
So they made gold and we have Trump.
Ever since we have seen him come on the
scene, he has toted bringing about the
golden age. So let's go ahead and hear
him say it just for proof.
Of course
you guys probably aren't hearing that
clip.
Maybe
first.
Okay. So, it's not the first time. It's
not the last time. It's just been
bombarding our systems everywhere we go
that we're doing that. Okay. Let's go
back. Okay.
Man, this is going to be one we got to
edit on the back end here. No sound. I
see the golden age of America begins
right now. From this day forward, our
country will flourish and be respected
again all over the world. We will be the
envy of every nation and we will not
allow ourselves to be taken advantage of
any longer during every single day of
the Trump
administration. I will very simply put
America first.
And just due to my own pet peeve, I
don't want that toolbar at the bottom.
So, we're going to list it again. The
golden age of America begins right now.
From this day forward, our country will
flourish and be respected again all over
the world. We will be the envy of every
nation. And we will not allow ourselves
to be taken advantage of any longer.
During every single day of the Trump
administration, I will very simply put
America first.
America first like Babylon. Yes. And
we're hearing it everywhere. So the
golden age is coming. Yeah. The golden
age is upon us, if you will. So when you
look into that golden age, we've talked
about it. Check out our our other
videos. Go into the live tab. Look at
the different videos. We've talked about
the golden egg, the golden age, Trump,
all this stuff. The golden age is an
esoteric term for the age of Aquarius
where we're going to enter into this new
plane of existence where we're all like
reaching Christ consciousness. We're all
like enlightened. It's all about like
this Illuminati thing, you know, we all
want to be enlightened and everything.
Um it's really when Satan is going to
come and demons and externalization of
the hierarchy. That's what it's all
about is like Yes. The merging of the
spirit world and the physical world, the
age of Aquarius. Yes. And to divulge
some of that more based on
facts, we're going to get to that. So,
we have to explain what the meaning of
the golden age is just to make sure it
lines up. It means it often denotes a
period of peace, harmony, and prosperity
just as he's claiming. It also can refer
to a mythical primordial age where
people lived in abundance without labor.
Um so even I believe it's
um Helen Bllovsky or Alice Alice Bailey
believed that there were different um
the first race, the second race, so on.
So, I think this was supposed to be one
of the first races or ages where this
was already accomplished and we're
trying to get back to that. Yeah, we
talked about that on a video with Fron
and it was uh you'll have to check it
out. Aaron Fron, but it was talking
about that there was a time period when
all men were made out of lead or some
kind of gray steel. Is he going to go
into that? Okay, cool. Sorry, I'm
jumping the gun here. Yep, he's he is.
So, we just have to go into this and see
what's going on. The connection is
consistent with the deeper themes and
goals of oult secret societies, mystery
religions, and the great work or magnus
opus magnum sorry, magnumopus of
alchemy. The claim of transmuting lead
into gold, whether literal or symbolic,
is at the heart of occult traditions.
And it parallels the spiritual
transformation from base man into God
man. Man being hatched out of his golden
egg into a golden era of selfgodhood.
This is what ancient mystery schools,
the Anunnaki mythos, modern occultists,
and some elite Luciferian groups all
seek. It's often tied to ritual abuse,
blood sacrifice, and sex magic like
Hyros Gamos as the means to ascension.
So, that's a lot. I know it is, but we
do have a lot of uh threads to connect
tonight to see the full picture. So we
have Trump saying this, they've created
gold and now we have the understanding
that to create this gold unfortunately
there is a lot of the ritual abuse and
blood sacrifice and bloodshed that needs
to happen in their mindset. But the goal
through that is to be enlightened as a
man from lead to spiritual gold. All
right. So stick with me. Next
step first we're going to understand as
well the great work. It is a term used
in various contexts most notably in
hermeticism alchemy and the lima phma if
you don't know this is what uh Alistair
Crowley wrote this book of the law the
lima it's do what thou wilt that's what
all this stuff is and it's sex magic
with a K. Yes it is. And it refers to a
spiritual process of self transformation
and
transcendence. All right. If you jump
down below, in the context of alchemy,
the great work or magnus, sorry, I don't
know why I can't say that. Magnum opus
refers to the process of transforming
base metals, particularly lead into
gold. So, what's interesting, look in
the search bar, you see it's just the
great work. There's no context, no like
in alchemy or anything. You just type
the great work and it's going to show up
this alchemy lima hermeticism. And
notice the words the great work. What
does Trump always say? Let's make
America great again. It's all about this
great, right? And we know from other
videos, MAGA, make America great again
equals a sorcerer. If you go to the
Google translator and you put it in
Latin and actually many other languages,
a magi or a mage or maga is a sorcerer
and s alchemy is sorcery. So all of this
is coming together. This the fact that
science now in 2025 has made lead into
gold and it's alchemy and it's under the
MAGA
uh presidency and make America great
again. the great work, the golden age.
Look, Trump was saying the golden age
months ago. This just happened. Remember
the news article said that all this
happened like two days ago. So, I don't
believe this is just coincidence. I
think this is all part of the plan.
All right. And uh the thing that's going
to shock most of us, I believe,
is before we get to this is
that how they're supposed to accomplish
it a little deeper. and what full result
they're looking to achieve through this.
Because if this doesn't explain kind of
why the world is what it is and why you
wondered why there's so much I I'll just
say junk bad things in the world. Yeah.
Uh this should pretty much spell it out
for for us and I will try to explain a
little more as we go. But as we go on to
connecting these dots, we mentioned all
these things and we got to the egg. Now
let's look at the actual cosmic egg in
the occult. Um we have this egg and it
is the union of the opposites. This is
female and male in one being called the
reebus. We have covered this in the
cosmic egg um episode episode. So go
look at that a little further. But this
also pretty much
brings dark and light. That's why the
sun and the moon you have all these
different elements happening. Compass,
the square and compass, right?
Basically, it's making all differences
disappear so there's one union of
everything. Yep. Um, notice all those
six-pointed hexogs floating around with
these male and female symbols. And I I
think it's Mars and Venus. And in the
middle between the two up here, you'll
see this symbol which is a merging of
male and female. This is Mercury. Uh if
I thinking properly, the symbol for the
planet Mercury is this combining this
transgenderism thing that's going on.
Transhumanism even. That's right. Okay.
So, just to prove to you guys again, we
covered this further in the other
episode on this,
but these are bunches of different um
cultures that have stories of the cosmic
egg and how world mythology got started.
So you have the pelasian, the Finnish,
Persian, Slavic, Chinese, Egyptian,
Polynesian,
Greek, Hindu, Dogen, Japanese, and
Bantto alone are represented there and
how they say all of the the world got
started out of an egg.
Yeah. So it must not just be the occult
idea. It must be that this is
everywhere. Yeah. Well, the occult,
yeah, is covering a worldwide occult
belief. Now, it's crazy because all of
our videos are just tying into what 2025
is is pushing, the KFC golden egg. If
you watch the Golden Egg episode, you'll
see more about this whole thing. Mhm.
But um there's this guy right now named
Chris Bledsoe that's he's a
self-professed Christian, outspoken
Christian who had an alien encounter and
he says these are good angels because
they healed him. So he's saying because
these supernatural beings healed him,
there's no way they could be evil, no
way they could be bad. And he says that
he sees a woman named Hathor, which this
is an Egyptian goddess. He says that he
sees her every Easter. And what is
Easter based on? Easter's got the the
eggs, right? The fertility goddess. And
Hatheror, when you look at what where
she comes from, her origins, she fell to
earth or came to earth in an egg and
fell into a river. Now, look at the Blue
Origin thing with Katy Perry and some of
these other ladies that there was this
whole divine feminine fake act. The
whole thing was fake, but the ritual
where they're ringing the bells and all
this stuff. They were invoking Mott, M A
T, another Egyptian goddess who came to
Earth in an egg, in a river. It's the
same goddess. It's Satan repackaged
himself in different ways to different
cultures. And why now in 2025 are we
trying to invoke this female spirit,
this female goddess from this egg this
is going on right now. Okay. Yes. So
that's a little short background. Now a
little bit back to where we're going. Um
next slide, please. Okay. All right. So
we need to understand a little more
about this. So we're going to read
straight from where it's coming from.
Alchemy led to gold.
In the in occultism, lead represents
base human nature, carnal, ignorant, and
fallen. Gold symbolizes divineized man,
illumin
illumined, awakened, and godlike.
Interestingly, Trump is now divine. When
he got into office, they inaugurated him
underneath that um I can't remember the
terminology, but yeah, a Hiosis of
Washington, which literally means George
Washington to make a god. And they did
that to Washington. And now Trump is
like the first person to get inaugurated
underneath there. Well, somebody did a
long time ago, but it's not normal,
right? Okay. And we covered that also in
a different um episode. But continuing
on, the great work or magnum opus is not
just chemical but spiritual. is to
become as gods. Alchemists like
Paraselis. Okay. And Newton, yes, the
physicist and Rosacrruian used esoteric
symbolism for internal transformation,
what we'd call Luciferian
enlightenment. All right. There's also
the Anunnaki who were had an ancient
agenda. In ancient Mesopotamian texts,
the Anunnaki were gods, likely fallen
angels or Nephilim, who claimed to have
created man as a slave race, brought
forbidden knowledge such as technology,
weaponry, and sorcery, and desired
immortality and eternal rule over
mankind. Their agenda aligns with
Genesis 6, Enoch, and post flood mystery
religions, pushing humanity towards
transhumanist godhood and rejecting the
creator. Wow. Okay. Yeah, that brings it
a little closer.
That's what this Reebus thing was. The
two people that were pushed together and
the symbol above it. That's all all that
is about transhumanism. Um Aubrey did a
show. You need to check it out. It's
under the live tab. It's called Dark
Origins of Androgyny. It goes way deep
into the I mean it's like three hours
long, possibly longer. And it's so deep
about how these occultists believe to
reach the highest state of
enlightenment, you have to become
non-binary basically. And it's it's all
all this is going together with
transgender, transhuman, golden age, all
this stuff. It's crazy how it's all
coming together. Yes. Okay. So, let's
dig a little deeper into this union they
call the sacred marriage or hyros gamos.
It's an ancient ritual of divine union
often reenacted. It is reenacted in
secret societies. Symbolizes the fusion
of opposites, male and female, heaven
and earth, spiritual and physical.
That's what the checkered board floor is
all about with uh the Freemasons, too.
Okay. Interesting. In elite occult
circles, this becomes dark sex magic,
often ritualized with trauma, abuse, or
sacrifice to channel spiritual power. So
keep that in mind. Unfortunately, that
is where it centers around quite a lot.
This is according to Alistister Cwley
Simma and the Otto, the order of the
something. I don't remember what that
means, but this practice is deeply
encoded into elite esoteric systems,
Freemasonry, Jesuits, mystery schools. I
know for a fact that is true, and also
satanic sacrifice and abuse. We need to
look into this. There are many
testimonies such as whistleblowers and
survivors and symbolic evidence from
high societies that indicate that ritual
child abuse is not random. It's a
deliberate ancient right. So if this is
your first time hearing that, please,
unfortunately, you need to understand
this gruesome fact. It's
true. It's deliberate and it's an
ancient right. trauma. Why they use
trauma is it's supposed to open up
portals that splits the
soul and
enables
spirit possession or programming.
And yes, blood rituals and abuse are
believed by a cultists to feed spiritual
beings, demons, and empower the
magician. This is all why we have this.
And if I can speak on it for a moment,
this is why they
have they
have I've heard I guess let's backtrack.
I've heard a lot of people and I feel
the same. Why can't they just stop all
of track trafficking, sex trafficking
even? Yeah. Um porn sites. Why can't
they just completely turn them all off?
Well, this is why they won't. Yeah.
Because they're in on all of it. And all
of it glorifies their god and their
agenda that we're getting to this cosmic
age to come about. And we just wonder
all of this, why is all of this so we
have missing children, right? And we're
looking for them all the time. We got
the posters.
Well, I happen to know from my research,
even though I have not been able to
compile it yet, on satanic ritual abuse,
that most of those children went missing
because they were used for those kinds
of human sacrifice rituals.
And so they are they're gone.
And
um that was from one of the high
priestesses
of Satan worship who came out and became
a Christian and gave that testimony. So
just to address this, this is why like
this is so why Yes, exactly. Thank you,
Stephanie. That is why Diddy and those
rituals and abuse steals that victim's
soul and what he was doing by his abuse
of kids and others. They will always use
kids and we'll see why. Okay. Um, not
always, I guess, but basically kids are
kind of like
their best kind of
victim. All right. So, I hate to have to
spell that out, but I kind of need to to
put the whole picture together. So,
well, because Satan, he wants to pervert
and corrupt everything that God has made
pure. And children are as close as you
can get to purity. I mean, Jesus said,
"You must become like little children to
inherit the kingdom." So, the best thing
that they can do to get the most power
from Satan and
demons is to go to do the worst thing
you can ever think to do, hurt a child.
And on this slide here where it talks
about um trauma opens portals, and this
is what MK Ultra is all about. It
actually says MK Ultra right there.
That's why these celebrities who sell
their souls to be gods on earth like
Britney Spears and all them, they go
through this traumabased mind control MK
Ultra where their
minds are fragmented so that they can be
easily controlled by the spirits to be
puppets, Illuminati puppets to the world
to brainwash humanity into
falling into all kinds of satanic traps
like Mhm. Um, over the years it's it's
just been a downward spiral. We talked
about that with the satanic uh sitcoms.
It was a it was little subtle things in
the beginning like Lucy lying to her
husband or whatever and then it just
gets worse and worse to like Al Bundy
hates his wife. It's always about trying
to manipulate the minds of the masses,
desensitizing us to what is right, what
is wrong, and everything becomes
normalized to where it's like, well,
yeah, of course, families don't stay
together and husbands uh hate their
wives and they long to be with another
woman and the the daughter is a [__]
and all these things. That's normal,
right? So these people who have sold
their souls, they're doing it under the
contract that we will push a message and
that message is sexuality, the occult.
Just listen to what like Britney Spears
sings about and Katy Perry with Dark
Horse and all this witchcraft and all
this stuff. Lady Gaga, all this stuff is
because they sold their souls under this
contract. They're being used by demons
and it's all with this fragmented mind
making them susceptible to with MK Ultra
and all this stuff. So, in these in this
research that we've looked
into, we think that this might even be
where some of these I don't know more
modern um
mental disabilities come from. things
that you didn't hear about 50 years ago.
Uh being on the spectrum and things like
that. These could be things that the
elites have caused have been using
humanity like a guinea pig or a petri
dish. And all those injections you get
when you're born and whatever they're
putting in the food and the water and
the air and all this stuff is creating
a I don't want to say a race, but
creating a a sect of people who are more
easily
controllable. Satan wants this. Satan is
trying everything since the Garden of
Eden. How can I take over God's
creation? How can I corrupt it? How can
I pervert it? How can I possess it? And
he's gone so far as to manipulating
people's genes, fragmenting their minds,
and all the stuff that we prot
participate in, the music we listen to,
all that stuff has uh an effect on our
mind and pornography and all this stuff.
They can look at the brain of a porn
addict and they can see the damage that
it's caused. All this stuff is allowing
you. This is just like, okay, proof that
you can see how Satan is getting into
your life. Yeah. And
we well I will get there a little bit
more too. Um down into media and
everything. We ask ourselves why the
media has so much junk in it. Well,
that's how they showcase everything at
once. Pandora's box is unleashed to
every person to see all the abominations
of the world to become like them. It's
imitation that they're wanting. Yeah.
It's uh the knowledge of good and evil.
Something God never wanted us to take
part in. Right. Okay.
So let's continue. The golden age and
Trump. The idea that Trump ushers in the
golden age is deeply rooted in new age
and luciferian ideology, not biblical
truth. His presidency has been
symbolically tied by some to the rise of
the phoenix,
Qanonosis, and the age of Aquarius.
Golden age in a cult language doesn't
mean Christ's reign. Listen closely.
Isn't that interesting? It actually
means Lucifer's counterfeit utopia. A
time of false peace before total
control. Think the Antichrist system.
Yeah. The alchemal, sorry, alchemy gold
announcement is symbolic. They're
telling you the great work is reaching
its climax. Wow. Yeah, we're there. I
mean, if anybody was ever doubting the
signs of the times, I mean,
2025 is a year where nobody has an
excuse anymore. I mean, years ago, the
distractions, the lack of information,
whatever it was, there was
a potential for ignorance, but not
anymore. I mean, the signs are
everywhere, right? Okay.
So, we just have to keep digging into
this because it's going to keep giving
us little nuggets to to um connect. So,
esoteric or spiritual gold. This is the
real goal of a cult alchemy. The
enlightened gold like man is what the
serpent promised in Eden. You shall be
as gods. Genesis 3:5.
Lead represents fallen man. Gold is the
perfected god man. This is deeply
luciferian and linked to this is an
interesting tidbit. You should take note
of this. It is linked to and mentioned
in the cabala hermeticism, narcissism,
crowian magic with a K. That means sex
magic, masonic initiation. Yes, that is
true. I have actually heard again I have
the video on survivors actually being
able to testify that this is true. But
whether literal sacrifice is used or
not, the energy source is demonic. And
many do rely on ritual abuse, trauma,
and sex magic to unlock ascension.
So, can you achieve a cult enlightenment
or spiritual gold without perversion,
sacrifice, or rebellion against God?
Absolutely not. This article says
according to Alistister Cwley, no one
one cannot do that, right? It makes
sense
because why is Satan going to empower
you if you're not fulfilling his
mission, which is to destroy and corrupt
God's creation? And so when he offered
Jesus all the kingdoms of the world,
which he still has the authority and
power to do, he's the god of this world,
Satan is. He said, "Bow down and worship
me and I'll give you everything." He's
still offering that offer today. And
many people are taking that. Most of
them are in the elite world. They're
literally living like gods. And most of
them that I've seen in interviews and
stuff, at least years down the road,
they start to
um they start to what's the right word?
Uh dulge. No, reject uh re I don't know
why I can't think of the word right now.
They start to regret that decision. Oh,
yeah. Yeah. They're like, "This is not
what I thought it was going to be." Like
I I pictured like you know fame and
fortune and I get to do what and these
people are slaves. Yeah. Literally
slaves. Yeah. They say I'm not as happy
as I thought I was. I thought if I had
money I'd be happy and and fame or I
can't trust anyone. I don't have any
true friends. I Yeah. I didn't know that
I wouldn't be able to go out anymore.
Right. Stuff like that. So it's crazy.
Okay. the idea of portals. Now, we
already mentioned that creating portals
unfortunately in someone by causing
trauma. But here's a different kind that
we have to be aware of. It says the idea
of portals align with real documented
occult symbolism and the beliefs of many
highlevel initiates in
Luciferian
Saturnian and mystery religion systems
which connects with this golden age and
cosmic egg and how it is to be brought
about. So listen up here. They're going
to also showcase a truth bomb that
connects with this. These happen through
black cube portals or altars of Saturn.
The black cubes. All right. If you have
been paying attention in most of our
life here, we've seen large black cube
monuments appear across the world, such
as listed here, New York City, in the UN
meditation
room, in Mecca with the Kaba, Australia,
Germany, Denmark, and more. Even in
Saturn themed art and tech branding,
you'll see that in a minute. But these
are not random. They are altars or
portals in a cult belief connected to
Saturn worship. So now we have the
element of Saturn worship coming into
this. Okay, so stick with me and we're
going to see some examples of how this
works. So these are the exact pictures
from some of these places. Just so you
guys know, they are real. They're there.
I hope that you have seen them before.
All
right. And they are in branding like
they were mentioning. They actually if
you really pay attention to branding,
it's everywhere. It is literally
everywhere. Yep. There was even a a
console, a gaming console called Sega
Saturn. And interestingly enough, inside
Mecca where all the Muslims circle
around that big black cube in prayer,
inside of there is a meteorite, some
black fallen rock, black rock.
And it's just crazy. This this whole um
lure about this thing fell from heaven.
And it it's satanic. It's like the the
fallen angel, you know. However, once
you mention that
connection, if you've been with me on
some of my other episodes, you will
realize that the priests of Saibel
always wore a black meteorite around
their neck because that was a symbol of
their devotion. So, now we're starting
to understand that that's right. It's
here to stay and it's actually being
used today as well. It is in the
Transformers like someone mentioned. It
could possibly be um on Trump Tower. I
haven't looked at that, but it is used
in so many places. Yeah, I mentioned a
game system called Sega Saturn. There
was also a black cube called Nintendo
Gamecube. The reason that these gaming
systems use it so much is because how
many people in the world are literally
controlled by these games? I mean, video
games is one of the strongest addictions
we have today. Yes. Yes. I mean, I see
grandmas with their phones sitting there
playing Candy Crush and stuff. Mhm. Just
consumed. Yeah. And almost every device,
just to put that out there, every device
is actually shaped Yeah. in a square or
a like a symbol like that because it
comes from this cube of Saturn type of
idea. But just to know a little bit
about Saturn worship, he's called the
great father time. These are a few
depictions.
his you can see the star of Moolok there
which is one of his symbols. Yeah,
that's a picture that's
on a book of Solomon or something. I
can't remember what the name of this is.
Okay, so it has a concise description
here. It says the planet Saturn is known
as the dark sun. Keep that in the back
of your mind as well. Thus, the god
Saturn is characterized as being cold,
dark, and evil. In ancient Rome, he was
the most evil of the gods. Also, keep
that in mind. Today, millions of people
honor Saturn. He is the Hindu Brahma,
the Wiccan Pan, the Zen Buddha, the
Masonic Guotu. I don't know what that
name is, and the
Gnostic demi urge. Yeah, the demiurge.
Ultimately, Saturn is Satan. But in
antiquity, he was a deified Noah. He is
symbolized by the
mag imagine David the black cube Santa
Claus and we have the day Saturn day or
Saturday for him.
Okay.
So this is I hope going to connect very
easily for you. But they believe that
they are going to in the end produce a
result of bringing their
god this golden age will bring about
this their god through the portal who
will actually be with them on earth that
they will be elated to have. And it's
supposed to be through blood sacrifice.
Unfortunately, and this is why because
the belief system works like this. They
say number one, blood is energy. Ooul
cultists believe that life life force is
in the blood. This is echoed in
Leviticus 17 verse 11. They're just
using it very twisted. Yeah.
Um, so number two, mass death feeds the
spirits. Blood rituals, especially
involving innocence and trauma, open
portals or thin the veil in their
belief. This also goes for wars that are
we know are manufactured.
Yes, that is true
too. Um, and the black cubes equal
Saturnian altars. They are symbolic
gateways between our realm and
theirs. Number four, a golden age is the
reward. That is their goal. Optimally,
they want to bring it about. And it's
after the purification by death and
chaos, the new age god manifests
physically. Wow. This is echoed in this
is interesting that they mentioned this.
Bohemian Grove rituals, Crowleyian The
Limma
Magic, Jesuit Mystery writes, Luciferian
New World Order goals. Yes, they've been
talking about this for a very, very long
time.
So if Helen Botsky and Alice
Bailey actually I don't know if both of
them have they both talked about the
golden age but Helen Botszky talked
about this externalization of the
hierarchy in 2025. Yes. And that's
literally what's happening right here.
here. When you look, it says that
they're wanting to bring in a manifested
God, a new age God physically into our
world in the golden age. And Trump is
announcing it. We're in the golden age.
Yes. Um, while I'm thinking of it,
because it's been on my mind, too. Thank
you again, Stephanie, for that question.
What's Guatu? When it said
Masonic Guatu when I read it, this is
actually the great architect of the
universe in masonry when they speak
about it. That's why the G is in the
compass square and compass. Good
question. Yes. So, is this going to get
into CERN? Are you going into CERN?
Actually, no. So, I want to
mention that's what CERN is all about.
the CERN, the Hydron Collider, where
they have Shiva, the destroyer out there
and and the workers there. They've done
all these crazy uh ritual dances and
there's another Hydron Collider in
another country where they had a an
opening ceremony where all these people
were basically walking out like zombies
naked and allseeing eye on an LED screen
and all this stuff. These are these
literally are rituals. I don't know why
people think this is just oh man it's
just artistic expression. It is creepy
to watch these
u whatever they opening ceremonies. The
word ceremony means a religious
activity. Yeah. And so they have these
strange ceremonies that are definitely
satanic and occultic. and this hydron
collider. There's been so many
testimonies of people that say when they
work around those things or uh have
there was a college that had to store
some black matter or dark matter or
something in the college and people were
saying they were having spiritual
encounters and stuff. I believe these
things are literal stargates. I don't
think it's a a coincidence either that
Trump has signed for this thing, this
Stargate to happen, which is artificial
intelligence surveillance. And now we
have CERN turning lead into gold, which
is symbolic of the golden age, which is
about alchemy, which is sorcery. All of
this and these cub these cubic altars.
Yeah. Yes. The Stargate. Yes. This is
all initiation to bring Satan into our
world as the cosmic Christ. And the
people who worship him, well, they're
going to just see their God here. And
all the Christians who are expecting
Jesus to come back, they're going to
believe this is Christ. And all the
newagers, they're going to believe it's
um what's the one? Um, can't remember
the name of him right now, but every
everyone around the world are going to
see Satan as their god that they've been
waiting for. The Jews, they don't even
believe that Jesus is the Messiah. So,
they're waiting on a Messiah. It's going
to be the Messiah to them. It's going to
be Matraa to the new age. It's going to
be Christ to us. It's going to be this
cosmic Christ to these other occultists.
Yes. Or Lucifer. They'll believe it's
Lucifer. Mhm. because he was a an angel
of light that's trying to free humanity.
So all around the world, people are
ready to they're they're waiting for a
spiritual entity to come and save us
from this chaos that the elites have
manufactured. Yes. And someone asked
about abortions if that is them adding
to the blood rituals. Yes, it is a form
of that% for sure. Um, someone else also
had another question I wanted to this
one.
No. Oh, yes. Gaming systems. Like I
mentioned, they're always a cube of some
sort. Yep. Always. So, game cube,
Saturn.
Okay. So, here's where it goes deeper.
And again, we have to understand the
level to which this goes to for them.
For the dark
elite, they believe that the world must
be, and hear me out, they believe it
must be ritually purified by chaos, war,
and
blood. That children's suffering is the
most potent source of energy, which
echoes of adrenochrome rumors, but is
deeper. The coming of their god requires
a total inversion of God's order,
gender, family, sexuality, law, and
worship. Lots of bloodshed. And I mean
lots. I didn't put it on here, but there
was like an article that mentioned and
and showed in some ways their depiction
of just bodies strewn everywhere
and rivers of blood everywhere to
accomplish this portal to open and the
golden age to come.
Um, I want to read Revelation 14:20
because this was a connection with with
what Aubrey just said about the blood.
How much blood. This is this is a
fulfillment of prophecy in Revelation
14:20. And it says, "And the wine press
was trotten without the city, and blood
came out of the wine press, even unto
the hor's bridles by the space of a,600
furong." Yes, we're talking about blood.
as tall as high up if you could fill the
earth as high up as a horse's bridal. I
don't believe this is all at one time.
This is been Satan working over the
years killing in his name. Right. And so
if you add that up, actually I'm glad
you mentioned that because I've been
thinking about it because I always
thought, oh, we'll know when that time
comes when the blood is really high. But
you know what? I'm thinking in some ways
we don't because they're hiding it so
well when they take these children.
It's it's secret. We don't know about
it. We don't know what what really
happened to them a lot. They use all the
blood. They're doing whatever. It can go
through the sewer system and the
slaughter houses as well, consuming it
and they're tunneling. Yeah. They
consume it a lot of the time in their
rituals as well, but
they can channel it to different areas
underneath the cities and so on that we
don't even know about. So, we could be
in that time period and not even know
it. Like that McDonald's commercial of
finding,
let's just go ahead with it. It was like
baby parts in the nugget that that one
woman gave her child. Yeah. And why a
lot of people are not eating at
McDonald's now. And it was found in
different restaurant as well. So, I
think they're wanting us to also consume
the remains of these people and the
blood. And so they're channeling it into
different food sources perhaps that are
processed and like I said, channeling it
into different pathways under the
ground. So we don't even see a lot of
this happening yet. But that made me
feel like we really need to be very
close. We are close to the end. Oh yeah.
And we don't even know it. This is some
of the secretism or secretiveness um
that will be kept from us I think so
that we
are tempted to think it is not upon us
yet. Yep. And remember when when we're
talking about these elitists, these
occultists who sold their souls to Satan
and all that, we're talking about the
people that rule the world whether
politically through music or whatever
entertainment industries. remember these
people, um, Gwen
Stefani, Lady Gaga, all these people
that have been seen at these spirit
cooking parties. And that's that's stuff
that photos that have been leaked out.
And just think about like what we
haven't seen. Yes. The things that
haven't leaked out, the photos that
haven't leaked out, all this diddy stuff
that's coming out, all this stuff is is
surfacing now
because it's just it's it's too much.
The Bible says that every secret thing
will come to light in the last days. I
think we're there. Yeah. So, to finish
that slide off, um we're down by the
golden age is not peace under God like
many that like they're going to portray
it. Um it's Lucifer's counterfeit
utopia, as I said before, after massive
destruction. That is key after massive
destruction. These themes are even
present in predictive programming movies
like The Avengers,
Prometheus, Eternals, Noah, Children of
Men, etc. We have seen this. Oh, yeah.
But yeah, um the UN meditation room, if
you have not seen it yet, that is quite
something. It says, "Yes, the UN
meditation room in New York is
especially revealing. Inside is a
monolithic black altar." Wow. It is
black made of
magnetite. The founder of it said it was
for those who kneel before no visible
altar. The room's proportions and
lighting, now listen up, are occultic,
intended to channel energy. Behind it is
a mural described as abstract but filled
with esoteric symbols of
sacrifice, birth, and the allseeing eye.
Of course, this is essentially a temple
to Saturn masked in secular language.
Saturn worship can also be called the
black sun cold. Man, that I'll just
leave you with that because when I
looked it up, it got me down a whole
rabbit hole. Like, I just studied that
for days on end. The black sun cold.
Yes. Oh, yeah. Yeah. It opens up a whole
another video. Um, I did get into it on
a rain.
Yeah.
Um, so the black sun, here's a few
tidbits I'm giving you. Schwarz Son is
actually what the SS for Hitler's army
stood for. Um, and is an oult symbol
representing the invisible or esoteric
sun. This is important as well. It's a
hidden light or luciferian source of
knowledge. It is linked with Saturn
worship as we saw with the black cube.
that Saturn
worship. The black sun is also linked.
Another piece of the puzzle comes to
light. This is Kronos, father of the
gods, devourer of children. Also, solar
eclipses when the true sun is over
shadow. Do you hear me? Yeah. They're
going to break it down right now.
Negretto is a term also called the dark
knight of the soul in alchemal
transformation. In oult systems, the
black sun eclipses the visible sun
symbolizing the inversion of true light
Christ with the false light of
Lucifer. Okay? And that's going to be
meaningful in just one more step here
because you're going to see how it all
connects. That will bring us full circle
suddenly. Okay, here we are. When the
world unites in Sunday worship,
especially under a coming one world
religious system, it will appear good.
That's what this golden age will also
bring. Yeah. But in truth, it will be a
ritual of false light, preparing the way
for the manifestation of the Antichrist,
the beast system that replaces God's
commandments with man's authority. H
like it says here, he shall think to
change times and laws, which is is
exactly the role of Saturn. He is the
father of time and laws. Yeah. Okay.
Wow. So, yeah. I mean, you just read
that Daniel 7:25. If you guys haven't
heard this, this is a prophecy about
Satan, the Antichrist, the whole beast
system that's coming. And it says, "He
shall speak great words against the most
high. He shall wear out the saints of
the most high and think to change times
and laws, and they shall be given into
his hand until a time and a times and a
dividing of time." Yes. And the only law
of God that also relates to a time is
the Sabbath commandment. Right? What is
the only commandment that Christians
have been tricked into rebelling against
and saying we don't got to keep that
one? You know, we even saw um
recently Ray Comfort from Living Waters
um saying that we don't have to keep the
Sabbath. I mean, this guy goes up on the
to people on the street. He debates
them. He's witty. He's quick to respond
to people and make atheists like think,
make their wheels turn. And then he he
confronts them with the Ten
Commandments. Are you a good person?
Well, the Ten Commandments say you're
not. And yet a person like that, as as
much of a Christian, ministry-minded
Christian that he
is, still will put out videos that say,
"Well, we don't have to keep the Jewish
Sabbath, the fourth commandment." Right?
It's mindboggling. I I I can't
understand it. But this is
how the the dragon is going to deceive
the entire world. Revelation says the
dragon deceives the entire world and
it's all going to be under this one
world religion of coexist. And like like
I said, every every kind of religion is
going to see their own god. And this guy
who's a Christian, Chris Bledsoe,
believes that Hathor is the Holy Spirit.
So just imagine when we are faced with
the externalization of the hierarchy,
when we are faced with um heathen
deities manifesting in our
world, we're going to have to rethink
everything. If you're not grounded on
the truth, you're going to have to
believe what your senses say. And
there's going to be a lot of deception
out there. Like look, you guys are
dividing over something. It's all the
same. You the the Egyptians, they
believed in God. The Babylonians, they
believed in God. the Christians, the
Catholics, we all believe in God. You
guys are dividing over something. We
need to unite on this. We all believe in
God. Look, he's here. Like the Messiah
is here and and you're dividing over
these things. And this is why it's going
to look
so it's going to look so much like the
truth because it's it's based on peace
and safety. It says when they say peace
and safety, sudden destruction will come
upon them. But this is what we're racing
towards right now. We we had our season
of chaos. These people make order out of
chaos. It's not over yet. I mean, we
still got aliens are coming and all this
stuff, quote unquote aliens, but we're
going to start seeing some things that
we've never seen in our entire life.
We're going to be faced with things that
we've never had to face, supernatural
beings performing lying signs and
wonders and miracles, even healings.
And we're going to have to understand,
no, Christ is never going to set foot on
the ground until after the millennium.
Like when he comes, like lightning
flashes from the east to the west. The
dead in Christ are going to rise first
and the living righteous are going to be
caught up to meet the Lord in the air
together. That means he stays in that
cloud. He never steps foot on the
ground. That's right. Until after the
thousand years is finished. I know
that's controversial because people
think that there's going to be a
thousand years millennial reign on
earth, but that's how twisted Satan has
made these doctrines.
He created a a doctrine where Christians
are actually looking for Christ to set
up a perfect kingdom on earth for a
thousand years. It's going to be for
eternity, but it's going to happen after
a thousand year. Uh it's a big study,
but basically read Revelation and you'll
see where it says after the thousand
years is finished, the rest of the dead,
the
wicked, they're raised to life to their
for their judgment.
And and that's when they're going to be
thrown into the lake of fire. They're
going to be consumed and gone forever.
They're not going to burn for eternity.
They don't have eternal life. They're
going to be consumed in the lake of
fire, the second death. Christ is going
to wipe away all our tears. And he says,
"There will be no more pain, no more
sorrow." All that to say, Jesus said,
"When they say I'm in the secret
chambers, don't go. When they say I'm in
the desert, don't go." We're not looking
for Christ to come set foot on earth.
We're looking to be caught up to meet
him in the air. If anyone, if any
supernatural being, I don't care how
powerful, how miraculous they are, Jesus
said, "Don't go for a reason. It will be
that deceptive." our senses, they say,
as human beings will be tested so
heavily. Even if you are a follower of
God to the point where seeing the
antichrist or seeing all this happen and
their miracles and all this stuff happen
that's attached will make us
emotionally want to love this person and
and believe that he is God. That's why
they even tell you do not go. Yeah. Do
not even tempt yourself with that. Just
stick with truth and resist the devil.
So go the opposite
direction. I mean it really does. It
means we are going to be so questioned
or questioning everything in our mind
and it says we will even doubt a lot but
we must stick with the truth that we
know. Yeah. Yeah. Because I mean imagine
you see all this and the majority of the
world is believing it. We're going to be
like am I being a fanatic? Am I being,
you know? Yeah. Yeah. So, I hope this is
encouraging in some way. I know it was
dark and things like that, but we are
trying to wake up the sleeping giant.
Like, Jesus is coming soon. I believe
with all my heart like 2025 is the
beginning of the end. We're seeing
things clearer than ever. I mean, this
is the strangest year ever. And it's
only May
and we need to get right. We need to get
our house in order. This is what we've
been talking about on this channel.
Like, get rid of the garbage that's
consuming your time that's warping your
mind. Let's get in God's word more than
ever before. Let's start planting
gardens. Let's start uh appreciating our
families and and God's creation and just
enjoying life the way God created it. I
want to be I want to start living now
the way I plan on living in eternity.
And I don't think that we're going to be
playing video games all day and watching
runchy
entertainment. And so we just want to
encourage you, get in God's word now
more than ever. Get in prayer. It's the
only way to overcome. Jesus when he was
tempted in the wilderness, he fought him
back with it is written. It is written.
It is written. It's the sword of the
spirit. It's the only weapon we have
against Satan. Right? If you guys like
this video, if you're blessed by it,
please give it a thumbs up. It really
helps this video get out into the
algorithm. If you're new to this
channel, hit that subscribe button, hit
the bell so you don't miss a single
episode. We try to go live at least once
a week and give you guys cool updates
like this about what's going on in our
world and how it ties into Bible
prophecy. We want to make the Bible real
to you. It's not just some ancient
history book. It's happening now.
Prophecy is being fulfilled every day.
If you want to support this ministry,
you can do so by going to cantruth.org.
We got Cash App, Venmoelle, PayPal. We
also have a Patreon that we haven't even
advertised yet, but I know it might just
be um harder to remember sometimes. So,
send a cash app every month or whatever.
We did a Patreon, so that'll be helpful
to you guys. And if you like cool
t-shirts, we got cool t-shirts. Go to
canatru.org. That really helps us out.
We got $5 per shirt sale on there. I'm
wearing one of them right now.
Be cool. Use your brain. And that's what
we like to do here on Can of Truth. We
love you guys. We can't do this without
you.